[Applause]
so
so
[Applause]
first of all
thank you thank you so much
for your warmth for your hospitality
for your kindness and for being here
tonight and we really are just going to
say a couple words and that is simply to
thank you not only for being here
tonight but so many of you i think we we
feel confident have been waiting two
years
guys
but more importantly you have and we
know that's probably not just the case
with this show but you've stood by and
been patient and enthusiastic and
optimistic and we simply wanted to thank
you because by doing that you have
supported our entire
theater community and that means all the
people you don't see back here
and all the people you've met in the
front
all the delis that's around our theaters
and the hotels and the restaurants and
every time you kept saying you didn't
want your money back for your ticket and
you kept going to restaurants
we are eternally grateful so on behalf
of my brilliant
[Applause]
on behalf husband every person working
in the theater in new york city we thank
you and we love you thank you
[Music]
you